Android 6.0, also
known as Marshmallow,
has a new permissions model
that streamlines the app install
and auto update process.
This new model gives your
users great flexibility
but you need to make sure
that your app behaves
as expected when they allow
or deny specific permissions.
Hi.
I'm Laurence
Moroney and I'm here
today to take you
through the steps that
will ensure your apps give
your users the best possible
experience in Marshmallow.
Step one, set your API
level and target SDK
to at least version 23.
You can see them in
your gradle code here.
Also, make sure that you
are using the V4 support
library to verify and
request permissions.
Add it to your gradle file,
if you don't already have it.
Step two, go back to your code.
When you connect to
Google Play services,
you first connect to
a Google API client.
It's a common step that
you may have seen a hundred
times before, but before
you skip over this,
it's extremely important
to set your code
to handle Google API client
connection failures gracefully
using the proper
resolution process.
For details and code samples,
take a look at the link here.
Step three, at this
point you've likely
connected to Google
Play services.
And it's easy to assume
that once you've done this,
that you can just go
ahead and call the APIs.
Well, that's mostly true.
Prior to Marshmallow, users had
to agree to your permissions
before installing.
So by the time your
code was running,
you could assume that
you had the permissions
to do what you needed to do.
In the new model, that's
not necessarily the case.
Before calling any of the
APIs that require permissions,
you need to check that
you have those permissions
every single time because
users may have changed
the privileges
granted to your app
and you may need to re-request
the permissions again.
You do this by calling
the check self permission
method on the activity compact
fragment or contacts compact.
You can see it here.
If this call returns false,
then the requested permission
is no longer available.
It might have been
previously, but it isn't now.
So don't call the API.
The good news is that this
request permissions method
that you can use to
inform your user that you
need those permissions and that
they can choose to grant them.
In the previous step, you
requested the permission again
and the system would call
you back with an on request
permissions result function.
So step four is to implement
this callback function.
The callback gives you a
request code parameter,
which you can check against
the particular API call types
that you want to access.
And if it gives you
the go ahead by passing
the permission granted
constant, then you
can safely call the API,
knowing that it's permitted.
Step five, if your user has
explicitly denied a permission
to your app but your app needs
that permission to continue,
you will need to manage
their expectations
and help them understand
what your app needs
for that specific
permission to function.
You can do this with the
should show request permissions
rationale method on an
activity fragment or context.
So for example, here you can
see that a permission has
been granted for fine location.
So UI can be generated
to tell the user that.
What this UI is is up to you.
It can be as simple as a toast
notification or an entirely new
activity.
It's entirely up to you.
From there, you can
go into the user flow
to request permissions
again but be
sure to be respectful and clear
in the message that you give.
And that's it.
Android Marshmallow is the
latest, greatest version
of this mobile operating system
and while the permissions model
has changed quite a bit,
it's pretty straightforward
to get your apps
ready to use it.
By allowing users to choose
their permissions when they're
relevant and in
context, instead of
being overwhelmed when
they first install the app,
their experience with your
app will be much better.
We have some great
samples that you
can look at and to
see how to handle user
permissions in Marshmallow.
Thank you.
I'm Laurence Moroney and you're
going to go build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]